whether it's a single shot or a
self-contained narrative a great opening
sequence is the most important part of a
movie the one that convinces your
audience to stay glued to the screen
until the end credits roll
and while the films on this list span
different genres time periods and
techniques all of them go to show just
how incredible the movies first few
minutes can be the Godfather starting a
movie with a monologue is a common
filmmaking device but the Godfather does
it better than any other I believe in
America America hasn't made my fortune
from the moment buona sera speaks the
seen such viewers into a story about the
immigrant experience but not the kind
with a happy ending the American legal
system has failed buona sera setting
free the man who beats his daughter
within an inch of her life his only hope
Don Vito Corleone played by Marlon
Brando by the time the scene concludes
we know that Don Corleone is a powerful
criminal but also the man who people in
his community look to for justice when
they have no one else and we definitely
know better than to change the channel
on Hammer Trainspotting the opening bars
of Iggy Pop song the lust for life will
be forever associated with this gripping
sequence from Danny Boyle's breakthrough
film which opens with a three-part
montage first renton played by Ewan
McGregor and Sick Boy played by Johnny
Lee Miller
running through the streets after a
theft then they shoot up heroin in a
run-down apartment and finally of course
they play soccer I mean football
football yeah
Wow same soccer fell so dirty the film's
other characters are introduced along
the way all while McGregor gives a
monologue about choosing life or rather
choosing heroine instead of life that
puts you in just the right mood for a
frenetic edgy and darkly comic story
about the horrors of addiction Halloween
John Carpenter's 1978 horror classic
heralded the dawn of the slasher genre
that would dominate the 1980s and he
opens with a serious scare the first
scene is shot from the point of view of
a killer spying on some amorous teens
before stalking and murdering one of
them in her bedroom a brutal event that
we see through the eyes of a mask for
the unseen killer is wearing but it's
not until the end of the sequence of the
killer's face has revealed the shocking
truth you've just witnessed a murder
committed by a six-year-old boy and
learned the origin story for iconic
serial killer Michael Myers who's still
terrorizing victims nearly 40 years
later rear window master of suspense
Alfred Hitchcock knows exactly how to
set the scene and he does so in this
case by shoving us the world through the
eyes of his hero who's a bit of a
peeping tom there's not a word of
dialogue in this sequence but you know
exactly what's going on this sweaty
photographer with a broken leg and a
wall full of action-packed photographs
is trapped inside his apartment and
starved for adventure which is hard to
come by when your sole source of
entertainment is spying on your
neighbors unless oh say you happen to
spot one of them dragging a body around
days done confused the opening sequence
of Richard Linklater's iconic stoner
film drops us straight into 1976 as an
orange 1970 Pontiac GTO circles a
parking lots and the Aerosmith suite
emotion plays in the background this is
where we first meet many of the film's
characters who are a score but also
don't seem to be taking their studies
especially seriously which all makes
sense when this title card reveals that
it's the last day before summer break no
matter what area you're watching it in
dazed and confused as you fully immersed
in its world in fewer than three minutes
star wars our new hope yes we all know
how this movie begins but try to imagine
watching its opening sequence in 1977
when it was a mind-blowing sci-fi setup
like nothing anyone had ever seen that
dramatic tech scroll the alien planet
a high-speed pursuit through outer space
featuring two starships blasting each
other with lasers but this wasn't just a
way of showing off star wars
groundbreaking special effects but
mismatch in size between these ships
makes it obvious that the first one is
the underdog which cleverly sets you up
to root for it even before you find out
that the greatest droids in the universe
and a very important princess are on
board Saturday Night Fever look at cool
dude John Travolta the physical
embodiment of all things disco
he's a woman's man no time to talk but
he does have time to shop by Pizza and
hit on a girl on his way to the paint
store where an annoyed customer is
waiting impatiently for his return
that's when we the audience realized
that the moments of joy he found in
those first few moments were stolen and
fleeting a distraction from his mundane
blue-collar life which is of course what
this movie is all about hustle and flow
first of all let's get one thing
straight see Manny lagging down that's
the opening line to an epic monologue by
Terrence Howard who has a lot to say
about the burden of consciousness on the
minds of men but there's a twist to this
philosophy lesson its audience of one is
actually a sex worker played by Taryn
Manning who's getting a lecture from her
pimp on why she should keep sleeping
with men for money
it's a game-changing moment that sets
the stage for everything that comes next
and the genius way to get the audience
hooked
the Dark Knight this opening scene of
Christopher Nolan's most beloved Batman
flick is a mini movie in its own right
an exciting five minute short film about
a bunch of criminals and creepy clown
masks pulling a bank heist after this
anonymous man gets picked up by his gang
a complex robbery goes down along with
some important scene setting exposition
about the man who planned it so why do
they call me Joker
I heard wears makeup makeup yet gear
people you know warping
as each man finishes his part of the job
he's killed by his cohorts until there's
only one left and when he takes off his
clown mask yeah nobody saw that coming
to recap 5 minutes into the Dark Knight
and you've already gotten an amazing
action sequence an exciting twist and a
perfect introduction to Batman's
greatest enemy now that's how you start
a movie thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]